extraction has been extracted from the
top spot on Netflix following a heck of
a run as a top movie on the streaming
service that Joe Russo pens Chris
Hemsworth starring actioner was finally
knocked from its perch the movie doing
the knocking dangerous lies a twisty
thriller about a young woman whose life
is turned upside down when she receives
an unexpected inheritance it was a
foregone conclusion that extraction
would become one of the most popular
original films in the streamer's history
it's the kind of movie that could easily
apart a respectable theatrical run
brucei was fresh off co directing the
literal biggest movie of all time in
Avengers end game and Hemsworth was
fresh off of starring in it the flick
sported a 65 million dollar budget and
as a co-financed international
production it was shot on location in
Thailand and India giving it a
distinctive globe-trotting flavor it's
also pretty damn good scoring mostly
positive reviews and falling in line
with Netflix as viewership expectations
it was expected to have the biggest
premiere in the services history and
what do you know it did knocking out
previous record-holder bird box the
movie is so popular the less than two
weeks after its release that's already
talked of getting a sequel into
production ASAP so what kind of an
absolute barn burner of a film that it
takes a knock extraction out of that top
spot we should celebrate
yeah well it's not a big-budget action
er instead a dangerous lies that densely
plotted thriller featuring faces that
are mostly familiar from TV the flick
stars Riverdale's camilla mendes as a
woman named Katey who works as a
caretaker for an elderly man played by
Elliott Gould when he passes away he
unexpectedly leaves Katie's entire
estate which happens to include a giant
stash of cash found on the property
Katie's husband Adam played by Jesse T
usher from the boys is thrilled with the
development being ready to leave their
financial struggles behind to start
living in the lap of luxury the
situation is complicated however by
several parties who are interested in
Katie's good fortune including an
investigator an attorney for the
deceased
and the shady real-estate agent reviews
for dangerous lies I've been mixed but
streaming audiences have absolutely
eaten it up
perhaps ready for a change of pace from
the big-budget bombast a non-stop
incredibly violent action of a
traction if that trend continues Netflix
viewers will soon be ready for yet
another shifting of the gears and there
are a couple of films climbing the top
ten that are coming up fast in dangerous
lies rearview mirror the strongest
candidate to take over the top spot is
all day and the night
a tense drama from writer director Joe
Robert Cole who co script dipped like
panther with Ryan Coogler
the film stars Ashton Sanders star of
the Best Picture Oscar winner moonlights
as a young man who was arriving for his
first day in prison as a film opens as
he does he looks back on his life from
his troubled childhood to the
circumstances leading up to his arrest
and incarceration to try to find a
better way forward the Dark Horse
contended to take danger slice down a
notch or two is den of thieves a 20-18
theatrical release which is making a
bigger splash on Netflix than it did at
the box office the flick centers on a
team of crooks who are looking to knock
over the Federal Reserve Bank in
downtown Los Angeles and the LA
Sheriff's Department Carper was bent on
taking them down this ensemble cast
includes Gerard Butler orange is a new
blacks published Schreiber and Curtis
50-cent Jackson with virtually every
household in the u.s. currently on the
lookout for something new and different
to watch it's doubtful that dangerous
lies will hang on to the top spot for
long considering all of the options
available on Netflix though its
ascension is pretty impressive
place your bets now as to who will come
out on top when with any luck dangerous
lies - and extraction to faceoff at
around this time next year check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos buy your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and at the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]